if you were to just poke the dry ice
with your finger it would come back red
with a slight prickling sensation to it
well because after just a few seconds of
having the dry ice in your hands your
skin cells would start to freeze and
then
die if you kept it in your hands any
longer your skin would begin to turn
blue and gray and eventually you'd lose
all sensation in your
hands and now
after learning about how damaging this
can be to your body you're still curious
enough to see what would happen if you
ate this brick of dry ice so as soon as
you ingested the dry ice you'd
immediately feel the same sensation you
did on your hand but in your
mouth your tongue and mouth tissue would
begin to sting and feel incredibly numb